uh we are taking calls via discord
at davidpakman.com discord
let's go to venice italy and speak to
emilio uh emilio i am tentatively
going to be in venice in 10 months for a
wedding if it all goes well
really very much so i'm telling this the
truth
ah perfect i'm glad you can have this
opportunity to visit this beautiful city
i look forward to it
thank you for uh picking up my call
and everyone like i would like to
tell you that you have a very
beautiful show unfortunately i cannot
support you right now because my income
now is a an intermitting
pace because emilia that's okay you're
supporting us
by just calling in and saying nice
things
and i i would like to talk to you to
talk to you about
a friend of mine she was at the
elementary with me
yeah she has the her father
is american okay and then she moved back
to
new york and uh before the
election she and his father they moved
back to italy
and he left the house the job
everything because she was really scared
of
all the situation about the pandemic
and of the turnout of the election
okay and from there i start
looking more
delicate more time to all this
matter because i always keep an
eye on international news but it was
really
upsetting all the all this
all the thing is going on in
your country yes unbelievable really
that is an understatement upsetting is
an understatement i agree with you
mm-hmm so thank you for picking up
my call and uh uh have a nice day
oh all right very good all right i i
appreciate it yes and if you
if you don't have a um
a flat an apartment you can contact me
oh all right maybe i will stay with you
yeah would we have to share a bed or
would i get
a sleeping bag or no we um
we sometimes we rent
a little button a very nice apartment
so if you if you are in
if you like this opportunity and now
hold on did you say little
and very nice or little and not very
nice
no no very very nice very nice okay all
right emilio i like the sound of that
all right emilio thank you so much
you're welcome you're welcome bye all
right bye emilio from venice italy
what a call that is just wild wild stuff
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
snh masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for covid19 and they're giving my
audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five-layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is
free on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david